bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors la démarche est
inédite car c'est la première fois
qu'une chaîne d'hypermarchés est assigné
en justice pour des faits de
déforestation que dit exactement la loi
sur le devoir de vigilance
alors bonjour la loi sur le devoir de
vigilance demande à ce qu'une entreprise
qui est basé en france et qui a des
filiales à l'étranger
un respecte un plan de vigilance afin de
s'assurer que les les produits tels
utilise ne soit pas issu
dans ce cas de la déforestation ou n'ait
pas d'impact sur le sur les hommes et en
l'occurrence les populations autochtones
alors votre ong fait parti de cette
coalition internationale qui demande des
comptes à casino quelle mesure le groupe
s'y prendre pour mettre fin justement à
ces violations des droits humains alors
le la problématique principale de la
déforestation qui se retrouve donc dans
les produits vendus par casino au brésil
donc grupo pao de açucar leurs filiales
au brésil et également en colombie
nous on demande à ce que l'ensemble de
la chaîne d'approvisionnement du boeuf
soit connue par casino
pas seulement les fermes direct mais
également les fermes indirects qui sont
les principales responsables de la
déforestation donc traçabilité et si
jamais il n'est pas possible de mettre
en place cette traçabilité
on demande un moratoire de
l'approvisionnement de boeufs issus de
zones à risque donc en l'occurrence de
l'amazone c'est une longue bataille
judiciaire qui est qui s'ouvre quels
sont les éléments les preuves dont vous
disposez alors c'est deux roses preuves
qui ont été accumulées avant même notre
notre notre investigation sur le sujet
qui est sorti en juin 2020 avait déjà
des preuves qui est qui était proposé
hélas le 3 mars conquis hier le jour de
l'assignation nous avons ajoutés au
dossier
l'épreuve qui ont été fournies par un
partenaire le ccca qui indique que de
2008 à 2020 le groupe casino s'est
approvisionné de fermes qui ont été
responsables de 50 mille hectares de
déforestation donc c'est vraiment un
problème systémique
c'est pas un problème qui est ponctuelle
de quelques fermes c'est vraiment un
problème qui est systémique et donc
voilà donc les preuves s'accumulent
depuis des mois et donc voilà nous cela
montre que la politique qui est mis en
place pour le moment par cna par casino
n'est pas suffisante
casino ou d'autres distributeurs
d'ailleurs au brésil ou ailleurs
elle n'est pas suffisante pour s'assurer
qu'il n'est pas de déforestation qui
soit qui se trouvent dans leurs produits
qui sont vendus dans leurs magasins
alors pour vous les distributeurs ne
sont pas les seuls responsables votre
pointe a également à la responsabilité
des pouvoirs publics alors les pouvoirs
publics sont également responsables nous
il faut savoir que en colombie ou au
brésil
les associations qui sont présentes sur
place nous ont dit qu'ils avaient besoin
d'appuis extérieurs d'appui de deux
pouvoirs publics comme la france enfin
de la france en général pour pouvoir
faire un effet de levier sur les
pratiques de groupes français ou
internationaux dans ces pays mais il ya
aussi la problématique de la
déforestation apporté à la france
continue à importer de grandes quantités
des déforestations via des matières
premières comme le soja dans ces cas-là
l'huile de palme les lois ou le cacao
donc voilà donc les la france aussi a
des responsabilités mais là notre
travail se situe à l'étranger donc aux
eaux au brésil et en colombie avec les
pratiques d'un groupe français qui est
présent là bas et il faut savoir que le
groupe casino fait 47 % de son chiffre
d'affaires dans ces pays là merci
beaucoup en tout cas boris pas trash
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes co fondateur de
l'association envol vers